we need to know what it is
period we need to know what they're
trying to achieve so that we can track
the progress or regress of it
how can you explain smart goals for your
protagonist yeah good question so i
actually do a series called story
elements on my youtube channel and one
of them is on goals and i talk about
smart goals so smart goals is an acronym
for specific
measurable
attainable
relevant and time-bound okay right and
smart goals actually was not uh created
for story but it works
so i have adapted it from like a
business model um to use it to teach my
students how to make goals for their
protagonists so specific means we need
to know what it is
period we need to know
what they're trying to achieve so that
we can track the progress or regress of
it
how will we know that they were
successful if we don't know what they
were looking for in the first place
right so your goal needs to be specific
the second one is measurable so that
again goes back to being able to track
it right we need to know are they
getting closer to it or farther from it
which is why i always talk about your
external goal being the personification
of the internal goal so if someone's
goal is to not grieve anymore how do i
track that what does that look like and
if you can
attach grieving to something external or
not grieving to something external then
we'll know that when they reach that
external thing then they reach the goal
and their grief has probably subsided
the third one is attainable which means
going back to social proof you have to
prove to me that my protagonist has the
skills to be able to attain this goal
because if not then i'm not going to
believe that they can do it right or if
it's a comedy then you're going to show
me that they don't have the skills to
attain this goal which means they're
either going to do a really bad job of
it or they're going to have to learn
along the way right or even in a drama i
don't have those skills so i have to
learn
those skills along the way and so now
it's probably going to be during your
debate time or somewhere in your journey
in your second act where they actually
have to learn those skills
the fourth one is relevant and i like
this one because this one kind of starts
to attach that internal thing to the
external thing it's like why does this
thing matter to this particular
protagonist so that goes back to
choosing the right protagonist for the
right goal having the right goal for the
right protagonist so if you can make it
relevant then we will invest more we
will empathize more and the last one is
time-bound and not every single story is
going to have something time-bound but
it's basically your ticking clock right
if this if there's a state of urgency if
like an armageddon you have 18 days
before the world explodes
then we understand that suspense is that
tension is going to stay there it's like
oh my god we only have 18 days and now
we have 12 and now we have 50 you know
however many days so adding a ticking
clock depending upon your story will
always heighten the stakes
so
if nothing else you need specific
measurable attainable and relevant and
depending upon what your story is you
can then add a ticking clock how else
can i write a three-dimensional
character
good question so
getting into the stuff of the character
is where that dimension is going to come
from people are complex we're not all
good we're not all bad we all have wants
we all have needs we all have flaws we
all have skills even before the inciting
incident happens so if you can figure
out what those things are then you will
figure out what's motivating your
character right i gave this example that
i am the youngest of six girls
but the closest one in age to me is six
years older than i am which would mean
that at age six she's twelve we don't
play the same right so we're not
interacting in the same way when i'm 12
she's 18. we don't play the same so
we're not interacting in the same way
because she's 18 she's graduating from
high school so now i'm in at home by
myself for another six years so even
though i have five older siblings i
spent a lot of time alone
so therefore i have an only child
kind of experience just as much as i
have a youngest child experience
that shows up in my life
i am an introverted extrovert a lot of
people know me as the life of a party i
have a big personality but i love being
alone
i problem solve alone
i do a lot of stuff by myself because my
history taught me to be able to be okay
with that right good or bad so
understanding those things about your
characters will let you know why they do
the things they do so there may be
people who say well shannon well why
didn't you call me on saturday we could
have hung out because they don't
understand that shannon just likes to
sit at home and
be by herself because she's used to that
that person may take it personally you
know oh well that's an offense towards
me you don't think that we're really
good friends and blah blah blah but it's
like no it really has nothing to do with
you and everything to do with me and the
same thing is true for your characters
they are acting and reacting because of
who they are where they're from an
immigrant is not having the same
experience in america as an
american-born person period if you know
that depending upon the kind of story
you're telling you can now infuse your
story with that stuff the same thing is
culturally as a black person there are
things that are going to happen in my
house that may not happen in someone
else's right so you have to then take
that and figure out how you can color in
the lines of your story with this
cultural stuff that makes it authentic
for them but the only way you can do
that is if you really take the time out
to know who your characters are and know
why they're making the decisions they're
making and now you can get
three-dimensional people the other thing
is it's 2021 so we're now doing the same
thing for our antagonist right our
antagonists get to be three-dimensional
now you know we're no longer in the jack
nicholson
joker time we're in the heath ledger and
the joaquin phoenix you know uh joker
time we're in the killmonger time where
we understand our antagonists just as
much as we understand our protagonist
which leaves us as an audience fighting
with those things and trying to figure
out who's right and who's wrong and now
there's discussion happening when people
go home but that only happens when you
take the time to dimensionalize your
antagonist understand what their plan is
understand what they want what motivates
them right which is usually the opposite
of your protagonist or the same right
like if it's a sports movie it's the
same we both want to win right if it's
um you know uh some kind of action film
then it's usually the opposite the
antagonist wants to kill people the
protagonist doesn't want them to those
are the reasons that they are in
competition with each other and i've
said before if we change the pov of the
story then your antagonist should easily
become your protagonist right your
protagonist is the antagonist antagonist
because that antagonist does not exist
because your protagonists exist that was
already a person who was already
planning to kill people
you came in and became a complication
for that person they didn't start
killing people because you exist they
were already a murderer and as a police
officer you came in and you you know
decided to uh to muddy it up so if we
were telling the story from the killer's
point of view
then now that would be our protagonist
right and they'd both be dimensionalized
enough to put us in the middle of it
right because they're stories about
vigilantes they're murderers
but they're doing it for a reason we
understand their reasoning and sometimes
we're on their side for it right so if
you give us uh if you do the work
because some of that work you're gonna
do is not gonna end up on the page but
it's still going to
um
dictate some of the uh choices you make
for those characters on the page
you